Congressman Jim Jordan represents the
proud state of Ohio and he joins us
tonight congressman is it odd to you
having served this country for what
lived in it for even longer to see
members of the press just going full Joe
McCarthy in accusing members of Congress
they don't agree with of doing the
bidding of Russia like where did this
come from nothing surprises me with some
in the mainstream press today Tucker are
going to be with you by the way but
think about this so this White House is
now working for put in this White House
to put more sanctions on on Russia than
than ever before this White House who
gave Ukraine tank busting javelin
missiles which the previous White House
which the Obama administration wouldn't
do and somehow the press is saying all
this White House is helping Putin that
is the most ridiculous claim I've ever
heard and I loved your monologue I think
you nailed it exactly right I mean I
just should say for the record I'm
totally opposed to the - these sanctions
and and I don't think that we should be
at war with Russia and I think we should
probably take the side of Russia if we
have to choose between Russia Ukraine
that is my view but but even with that
tell me what like okay well my comment
is haha it can't be both I mean so look
you got exist president right the Obama
administration gave him blankets as
ambassador Taylor testified in this
impeachment inquiry we've been going
through with the Democrats here he said
Obama Minister she gave him blankets
Trump gave him tank busting javelin
missiles that is a huge difference but
somehow a president president Trump is
working with vibra Putin I don't get
their logic I don't get it at all but I
don't get much of what they're doing
throughout this entire impeachment
inquiry they've been putting the nation
through over the last several months but
you wouldn't you think that after you
know whatever you think of the Russian
investigations ammonal report there
would least be a moment where people say
you know we promised you collusion we
can't prove it maybe we should I don't
know concede that we were wrong maybe we
shouldn't continue to bombard you with
unfounded allegations about Russia why
haven't they done that well you would
that would require some common sense and
some fairness on the part of the
mainstream press you're just never going
to get that particularly from the folks
that you were highlighting in your in
your monologue you're just not going to
get that from them they just double down
and keep pushing on and frankly that's
the same we hear from see from the
Democrat Party I mean that's the same
thing we see from Adam Schiff remember
he told us that there was going to be
collusion he
definitely see it there's been evidence
of it he guaranteed it would happen and
then when it didn't happen what did he
do he just moved on to this whole
Ukraine story that we've now been living
through for the past two months so they
never backed up and apologized they
never admit that they're wrong they just
keep pressing forward and it's driven by
something speaker Pelosi said two weeks
ago on a Sunday show when she called the
President of the United States President
Trump when she called him an imposter
that is the problem with it because they
they have never accepted the fact that
63 million Americans voted to make
Donald Trump president the United States
in an electoral college landslide
they've never accepted that fact and
they're out to get him and it just goes
from one thing to the other and they
never apologize when they're wrong yeah
it's getting too radical and crazy not
good for the country thanks so much for
that I appreciate that
Thank You Tucker